bon mon objectif est de fait car est
dans le faux choix vole aussi longue car
il est possible en fait possible je veux
avoir des malles louis d'or que sa soif
que ça soit ballon dans le monde en fait
[Musique]
je veux bien mauvaise
dans ma chambre
devait mettre les choses et il faut voir
ici le mario deschamps aussi les
chaussettes de football même le maillot
m'a mis beaucoup avec la vie de foot ma
vie c'est ma vie des filles car c'est
l'image et quant à péter claes qui reste
amusant qui m'a bien fait
[Musique]
ce
est ce lui de sare et entre en france
elle aimait beaucoup plus le ballon que
député je me dis vie doit aller à
l'école pourquoi pas devenir médecin
pourquoi pas avocate au départ j'étais
vraiment style mais à un moment là
insisté et avec l'appui de mes cousines
ma femme on dit mais il faut laisser
sûrement c'est dans le sang
ce matin
plus
j'invite toutes les disputes et et moi
j'ai enduré quand j'étais tout petit de
pratiquer le sport avec des garçons et
ne pas être confortable parfois être la
sortie et aujourd'hui elle avec nathalie
me bien sûr et autres centres à voter
elles ont la possibilité de travailler
les femmes
et des hommes
j'aimerais que mon pays et j'ai eu
après l'académie je suis invité
d'arriver au niveau comme fondatrice
dayen d'écrou fait écrire mais ajuste
tech d'afrique ou des hauts de deux ans
je me vois déjà entre deux
des jeux d'un grand club
peut-être à paris être vu dans tous les
médias être
en fait un exploit et tous les jeunes
la plupart des footballeurs qui
réussissent aujourd'hui sauter des bas
quartiers ce genre de terrain qui fait
des footballeurs des grands footballeurs
du nectar ou comme ça elles ont déjà
adopté un rythme elles savent qu'en
jouant ici elles nous rendent plus des
problèmes peut s'asseoir de toute façon
n'importe quel stade où on les surveille
maintenant dans n'importe quel pays et
qu'on nous donne le trouveront en deçà
des qui a des collines des bosses et où
on va s'en sortir parce que nous sommes
habitués c'est ça le monde sait ça là
qui fait la force des grands joueurs
jugés
notre prestation au canada en 2015 à la
coupe du monde l'évolution aussi avec le
nouveau président de la fédération les
chercheurs ito pense que lui qui connaît
vraiment les problèmes
du sport et tout ce que les footballeurs
ont besoin c'est vraiment
un plus pour le moment